je voudrais soumettre à votre réflexion
une chronique d'eric zemmour dans le
figaro magazine de ce week-end qui donne
le lundi qu'à sion suivante pour
expliquer selon lui le succès de ceux de
sept mouvements indépendantistes
catalans et d'yves et c'est normal
l'espagne a honte d'être une nation
depuis franco tout ce qui est fierté
espagnol a complètement disparu et comme
la nature a horreur du vide les bains
quand l'idée de nation disparaît et ben
série des deux régions qui prend le
relais périco légasse en arrêt bien vous
entendre sur ce sujet est ce que vous
partagez cette ce point de vue j'ai de
grands inconvénients d'autres basque oui
il est traîné sur jeudi à lire
géographiques où se pose problème je
connais cette histoire par coeur je suis
né dedans que c'est un prénom basque
péricaud et apprennent en bas c'est une
des façons de dire pierre en basque et
je suis d'une famille très impliquée
dans l'histoire l'identité basque je
connais bien le problème catalan je veux
reprendre de façon très simple je suis
désolé de dire que les médias français
se trompent de débat eric zemmour dit
qu'une partie de la vérité on va revenir
à des fondamentaux et il y a eu en 1919
un principe est dit
rédigé par le supposé a suscité par le
président wilson qui est le droit des
peuples concept du droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux mêmes l'espagne est une
nation comme le fut la france dans la
diversité il ya les espagne la france a
été plus rien avant d'être cette grande
nation rassemblée dans un destin commun
qui constitue là que les françaises où
on a adhéré au projet commun rappelons
que la fête de la fédération le 14
juillet 1790 c'est là ressemblement des
fédérations françaises la question est
simple est-ce que les catalans
constituent un peuple
oui ou non on a répondu oui pour les
slovènes oui pour les slovaques
oui pour les folies croate le kosovo
constitue un indépendant le
liechtenstein est un état indépendant
andorre le danemark luxembourg
est-ce que les catalans constituent un
peuple oui ou non s'il ne constitue pas
un peuple dira on envoie l'armée
évidemment c'est un peuple voilà bah oui
c'est un peuple déjà parce
qu'historiquement c'est un peuple la
catalogne est une entité historique
différent de l'histoire de l'espagne et
la constituent et l'espagne et ensuite
dès lors que nous avons c'est très
embêtant d'avoir des citoyens comme au
québec et comeau comme en écosse qui
disent nous ne sommes pas anglais nous
ne sommes pas canadien moi je me
souviens pendant les référendums
d'autodétermination du québec l'élite
jacobine de la france allait à la
délégation du québec
avenue de la grande armée pour assister
au référendum de jean maxime lévêque tu
es d'oeuvre est le suivant à on a perdu
mais on se remettait d'accord pour
déstocker canada donc il fallait donc il
faut réfléchir à la démence est légitime
jeu de maintenant je demande
d'application stricte du suffrage
universel